the inversion of the U.S treasury yield
curve is one of the most accurate
recession indicators there is the curve
is inverted before every recession in
modern history and right now it's at a
level it hasn't touched in more than 40
years I'm going to explain why the yield
curve inverted so deeply break down the
two very different possibilities this
suggests for the economy and detail what
this extreme inversion tells us about
the market let's get into it the
inversion of the yield curve we're
seeing more and more of it invert the
yield curve Now inverted investors
demand higher payments for taking more
risk so normally an inverted yield curve
tells us investors are worried about the
near future you can see that because the
amount of Interest investors demand for
bonds that are paid back in a short time
say two years is higher than the amount
of Interest they demand for bonds that
are paid back in a long time like 10
years the difference between the payment
on two-year government bonds and 10-year
government bonds reached 85 basis points
in early December that kind of inversion
hadn't been seen since 1981 but in
today's world it's all about the Federal
Reserve in the short term investors are
confident the FED will keep U.S interest
rates High we had two different fed
speakers yesterday basically we're
from the
higher for longer narrative talking
about 2024 possibly to hold rates higher
in the long term the extreme yield curve
inversion is being driven by the
possibility of two distinct economic
Futures the first is a soft Landing for
the U.S economy and the definition of a
softish landing is what unemployment
goes up a little but we don't have a
recession yeah inflation has fallen
consistently and jobs reports have shown
solid hiring in the U.S over the last
few months that's got bullish investors
betting that Trend will continue with
inflation falling back toward the fed's
target of two percent next year if
inflation cools down bond yields will
fall and when yields fall prices rise
making bonds purchase now pretty
attractive the second possibility is
that the US is about to go through a
painful recession we're not just going
into recession but we're going into a
deep one bearish investors are betting
that the FED will keep interest rates
High until job losses and economic
distress get so bad that they are forced
to reverse course and lower them that
would bring bond yields down and and
push prices up making bonds more
valuable as well strangely enough
falling inflation that leads to a soft
Landing for the economy and a hard
Landing that brings on a painful
recession would both be good for Bond
buyers and that's putting bullish and
bearish investors on the same side of
one trade the big takeaway is that the
market is telling us Bond investors are
confident that inflation is going to
come down one way or another we'll see
if they're right Bond investors are
hoping that in 2023 they can see returns
like dreamville head honcho J Cole who
said in God I trust so I get money
Faithfully not just occasionally gotta
make cake every day like I work for a
bakery
that's all for now see you next time
[Music]